welcome to this video yeah oops yeah
let's go let's go Sicilian a yam best
opponent and the terminal trying it
again now probably should study it more
I'm just trying that out but not ready
cannot really consider to be a
knowledgeable rb6 or Bishop e7 those two
those two move orders are possible yeah
maybe rook c8 95 could be handy asking
me about both the e porn and the sea
pawn it will go to see it anyway no it's
not reacting to it in any way if I will
Knight e5 yeah well I have to put that
on g7 a pretty much regardless and yeah
I'm not completely sure what this is
about the e power and the c4c pong I am
so that's a way to try to protect that
c4 pond okay let's play Queen c7 here or
do I have something better him let's do
that a taxi for again on b3 I might have
be five but black sorry Black has to be
very am cautious with those very quick
and openness this opening let's move
that open the position very quickly
because it's not i'm not very well
developed it should burn 93
Quincy five that doesn't lead to much
baby just develop here don't really see
em great move on still that that doesn't
feel very harmonious okay something like
d5 and then Bishop c5 comes to mind okay
but probably I have to Castle going d5
would be very thematic against his
somewhat misplaced queen can we go and
look the eight not not to try to try not
to spend too much time on this can
easily happen that you like I very often
do sink into deep thoughts how to
exploit the opponent's we had plain and
then you lose on time I came night ed
seven is certainly good night f to the
seven also might have some points
can also play Quincy 6 that's not a very
natural move maybe just really drop back
a gunite c5 next and that's not so bad
if I all night if I ya here 95 he has to
my doesn't have to go back but Valley he
almost has to we cannot really take that
d takes is pretty awkward and then
Bishop t6 so we probably has to return
the nitrous III but that looks rather
shaky some b5 d5 combination not sure
that it works though directly I don't
see something direct I mean it looks it
looks some a bit a bit shaky but can i
exploit it really move like b5 you will
take let's not really doing that much
okay if I scan every face getting in
Bishop to be true it's not so bad I
wonder if it's d5 a move maybe he takes
it with a pawn and then Bishop to d6
let's do that okay that's a bit of a bit
of a gambler because i didn't really
calculate it properly sorry for the
drinking sounds but it just in just two
damn Artyom if I cannot drink the odd or
turn water I'm simply sorry I'm simply
falling apart yeah well here you can
sacrifice immediately or you can play we
should be five I was actually thinking
Bishop b5 is better sacrifice on g three
hours I'm referring to but that looks
that looks better ready and i will not
be three and takes it bishop c3 and that
is at least in exchange
yeah maybe d5 was a good move it looked
like a good move so I'm just taking here
and now ed 5v5 looks normal then be five
probably t4 text rings yeah let's open
up okay here i can take e for Bishop f6
yeah that's not super clear I check
their take on d1 okay I didn't really
see a serious alternative right if this
have this Jan one of three if it takes
with the night can take on f3 and if it
takes with the bishop I guess I'll take
I'll take on f 63 takes and then
something like windy eight-time barham
should be ok I night the night move this
is awkward Nyjah for Nyjah form could be
i have i've got i've got checks on c5
that's good yeah Queen d8 was my idea
covering g5 and he cannot easily move
the night now as the bishop hangs that's
that's very useful and rooks you wanna
okay I think that should be too much if
i go to d2 now night f5 sitting that's
not good if i take i have 39 f5 key to
check
then negative 5 is really awkward maybe
just let's prevent that Nyjah for though
I'm is a move awkward okay it takes a
group d 1 I think I'm less for still in
time okay okay let's let's check that I
was quite interesting so somehow i don't
believe that this early leads to is a
great idea but werewell really am i'm
playing this um without a super detailed
knowledge but with that the setup looks
a bit wrong wyd it's not very harmonious
the question is if I could have done
something more forceful hi here be five
is strong yeah that's something that I
could have seen or d5 both a strong now
it makes them sets up to open this up
the ideas that couldn't be six I can
take you for now back be three okay I
overlooked night XD fried this pollution
that's not good yes it's very strong
okay this is not bad but it's not as
convincing he up here it seems that he
could have gotten was still had a fight
with the e porn taking with this I was
thinking Bishop t6 but then queen age
for seems to be still quite decent hmm
you went here
I went here yeah no I'm a much better I
am he has to give that h2 up because
this is just this is really winning yeah
he takes is also strong according to the
comp yeah probably it's just maybe a
little bit it's a somewhat um superior
version of the of the whole thing of the
game but ok it's a win here as well
check TX GTX Quincy 3 is even stronger
but okay I wanted to prevent any check
Queen d2 is good okay but I don't think
that this is particularly bad yeah so
it's a win so the second best moves were
we totally fine yeah the real problem
really was that that opening set up
where he went for this we had this
somewhat clumsy set up here these pieces
they don't tell harmonized very well
okay well thanks for watching